I'm going to teach you the entrepreneur
success formula this is the formula it's
very simple it's easy to apply that when
you actually execute it it will change
the course of your life and your
business the entrepreneur success
formula you need to combine what you
love doing with what brings value to
other people what you love doing with
what brings value to other people in
that intersection is your next great
genius amazing business idea here's what
most people do most people just pick one
most people either pick what they love
doing but they can't figure out how to
bring value to other people so you've
got a hobby if you love doing something
it just fills you up it's amazing but it
never brings value to other people then
you never get paid you've got a really
fulfilling Hobby and that could be great
and your hobby can be something you do
in the evenings and weekends and it
fills up your soul but you'll never turn
that into a business if you don't figure
out how to bring value to other people
so you're stuck always having to have a
job or go work for somebody else while
you're doing your hobby on the on the
weekends evenings on the side Etc so
those are the people who just Chase what
they love doing right chase Your Passion
name motivation what's your top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael
and we made these videos it's because
you're probably the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you need that
Push by surround yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best my husband Evan Carmichael and our
take on his top 10 rules for Success
enjoy
there's other people a lot of
entrepreneurs who just go after the
money
just try to bring value just go after
opportunity right that's the only focus
like I'll do whatever it takes I need to
be a millionaire by the time I'm X years
old I'll do whatever it takes but you
won't you will not do whatever it takes
because as soon as it gets hard you're
gonna lose and the problem is you're
going up against people who love it pick
whatever industry you open up a magazine
or website it shows you the hottest
businesses for next year these are the
industries that will take off and you
have to get into it it's like oh wow
that's hot I'm gonna go off and do those
things if you don't absolutely love it
right this part here if you don't
actually love it what you love doing
with it brings value to other people if
you don't absolutely love it
You're Gonna Lose because you're going
up against people who do love it if it's
just a strategy for you but for other
people they love it you're going to lose
every time you can lose every time
because while you're counting the hours
and while you're trying to figure out oh
my gosh when is this going to pay off
you're going up against people who
aren't even tracking it who get lost in
it who 12 hours later they're still
doing a thing because they love it so
much and they can't believe that where
is a time gone
so it has to be in that combination so
many entrepreneurs start a business
because if they're going to make a lot
of money and they end up going broke and
it wasn't because the idea was bad the
idea could have been fantastic the
problem was you didn't love it enough
you didn't care about it enough it was
just a strategy it was just an
opportunity for you instead of being
actually something that you love so the
entrepreneur's success formula
you start with doing what you love
and then you figure out how to bring
value to other people doing it rule
number two have a good morning routine
staying consistent on your morning
routine
is the difference between you having
a good life and a great life the life
that you're living right now which is
good listen you have a good life right
now if you're watching this you have
internet you have food you know you have
a place to sleep tonight you have a you
have a pretty good life
you have a pretty good life but it's not
a great life
you know you know you keep pulling more
you know you want to do more you know
that where you are right now is not
where you want to be that imagine a year
two years five years imagine if you were
still in the same spot in five years
imagine your life your health your
relationships your finances the impact
you're having your your routine your
daily like what you're doing on a
regular and nothing has changed in five
years
still be a good life but it's not a
great life
right it's not a great life
this is the struggle that you know
you're capable of so much more if you
didn't know you're capable of more
ignorance is bliss you just keep living
your life
but when you know you're capable of more
this is the the curse of the Achievers
like you know you're capable of so much
more no matter how much people look at
you and say hey wow you're doing so well
you're doing so much that that's why
you're watching these videos you are the
most ambitious person that you know
people look to you for guidance and
wisdom advice and support and
encouragement and hope and inspiration
like you're the one filling other people
up you're the one inspiring other people
to do better to be more to go after
their dreams that's you but who's doing
that for you
you know you're capable of so much more
and so how do you get it how do you how
do you do the work well it's a daily
thing this is this is part of the
challenge is it's a daily thing it gets
boring
it gets boring
through the exact same thing every day
to stay consistent on what you said you
were gonna do
and we start to doubt ourselves
you have days where you're motivated
inspired ready to Take On The World
feeling amazing and other days where you
don't feel so good and you think wake up
feeling like who am I I can't do this
what I said I was gonna do that you look
at your goals like I'm gonna I'm gonna
do that there's no way I'm gonna do that
me
I'm gonna stay in bed
it's a thing achievements don't talk
about is there's a lot of days when you
just don't feel like you're worthy of it
you don't believe in yourself you don't
think that you can do it
and it's just that consistency that
prevents you from doing the thing
because you have the days when you're on
fire and then entire days maybe a week
sometimes where you're just not doing
anything
and so how do you how do you keep that
momentum how do you keep that
consistency it starts with a morning
routine
and the goal of morning routine
is to help you feel
motivated bold courageous ready to take
on the day that's what the goal of a
morning routine is
everybody's got a morning routine if
you're watching this you got a more
routine everybody doesn't have a morning
routine most people actually wake up
like an accident right most people wake
up and they fall into their day and they
look at their phone and it's other
people's emergencies and other people's
demands for your time that's most
people's day but for you if you're
watching this
you're you're an achiever and you have
some kind of morning routine but most
people's morning routine are also broken
because you're not doing it consistently
enough or you're not doing it with
enough intent
so if you ask what's the goal of a
morning routine
the gold of morning routines to get you
bold and prepped and ready for the day
let me ask you this if you were to
for the next year of your life right 365
days the next year of your life you're
going to wake up
and do something that would make you
feel bold powerful courageous motivated
not asking you to wake up feeling bold
powerful courageous motivated but to
wake up tired however you wake up
I woke up tired today you wake up
and then you do something that will help
you feel bold powerful motivated
courageous and ready to take on the day
if you woke up into death for the next
365 how much is your life change how
much is the next year change how much
does the does the impact that you're
making does the actual momentum that
you're taking towards your goals how
much does that change
if for the next year you actually did
that
it should be tremendously it should be
dramatically because no matter how much
you do in your morning routine one
you're probably not super consistent on
it and two you're not getting the
feeling even if you are
that's what needs to change rule number
three tell your story your story is your
competitive Advantage why you do what
you do where you came from your history
all of the the baggage the imperfections
the vulnerability all of that your story
is the thing that's going to help you
win as an entrepreneur
this is one of the biggest
misconceptions and one of the hardest
things for us to do as entrepreneurs to
put ourselves out there and share the
story we want to be perfect we see these
big Brands we see people popping off on
Instagram and their perfect life and
their perfect planes and their perfect
marketing and we feel not good enough
and we feel like we have to be like them
but people can smell through it think
about it you're going up against some
big company right whatever industry
you're in there's some big players more
establishing you bigger budgets than you
deeper Pockets than you they've been
there forever they've got the brand name
the history the reputation people know
who they are and you're going up against
them why would somebody buy from you
instead of them
because of your story
because you're going to make me feel
special because in you I see myself I
see somebody who cares I see somebody
who's going to go off and make a
difference where I have no connection to
big company to a big Corporation but
what most entrepreneurs do is they try
to look the part of being the big
corporate they have a really formal
website they have a really formal
Photography they have a really formal
bio
at best you're going to be a junior
junior junior version of that big
company
I need to know why you do what you do
this is how you win your heart is your
competitive Advantage why do you care so
much and if you believe like I believe
that your purpose comes from your pain
that whatever you're doing right now
your deep purpose is to help other
people who currently are who you used to
be then I need to know what pain you've
come through
because you might have the answers you
might have the solution your product
your service your coaching your content
whatever could actually be the solution
but until I know that you've come
through the thing that I'm struggling
with I'm not going to listen to you
because I'm going to think yeah right
this person doesn't get it this person
doesn't understand me this person
doesn't care
meanwhile you do care meanwhile it's the
most important thing meanwhile you care
way more than anybody else cares but
until you actually share your story
nobody's gonna listen
this is one of the hardest things for me
to overcome when I started my business
because I always felt well nobody cares
about my story who cares it's not about
me I I have no need to be in front of a
camera I'm I'm introverted and shy by
Nature I know you may not believe that
in watching these videos but I am and I
remember fighting with my agent Steve
many times everyone that Steve nobody
cares about what I've done and my story
and I don't I don't like the spotlight
on me so why does it matter and after
years of fighting and hopefully what
took me forever to figure out if you
guys get this in this video you'll be
way further ahead than I was when I was
getting started
people learn through your story and if
you've got a message
you telling your story actually
perpetuates the message so you telling
your story it's not about you and your
ego and how you look and how people see
you and prizes and awards and anything
it's about making an impact because when
I know that you've been through what I'm
going through or I know how much you
care about something I'm much more
likely to want to hire you so let me
give you a couple examples
I remember I was doing a radio show and
when I first got started uh in in
coaching it was through a live radio
show that I was doing once a week I
remember one person calling in and he
had a landscaping business
and I asked okay well what's so
different about your Landscaping Company
because he was frustrated that all of
these teenagers and high school kids
were eating up his business where I say
hey we'll landscape your yard and we'll
do it for minimum wage and here he is
trying to make more than minimum wage
and he's worried that he has to compete
on price and he can't do it against
these teenagers and so I said well why
do you why do you care so much about
Landscaping man like why did you pick
this business and I hope for all of you
please that you have a story right if
you're picking a business just to make
money you've lost already
You've Lost That the entrepreneur
success formulas you got to combine what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people you have to love it you
have to have a story if there's no Story
You've Lost go pick something else that
you actually can't connect to
but I asked why did you start this
business what does it mean to you and he
said
my mom was my hero
and when I was young
she always took me out to the yard and
we did landscaping together
and it's always a connection to her
and then there was a line that he said
that really caught me where he said
every lawn that I go to every customer's
lawn that I go help I treat it like it's
my mom's lawn
and right there it's like oh my gosh
this guy cares so much like do you think
the average high school after school
summer job do you think they care as
much about your yard as this guy does
right if he's treating it like it's his
mom's Garden
and by sharing that story now you'd be
willing to pay more I'd be willing to
pay him way more than than a high school
kid because I think that he's going to
give a way better service provide way
more value because I understand the
story rule number four have an infinite
mindset
are then you want them to win with you
you want people to win around you your
friends your family your team your
customers the people you interact with
you want them to win as people in their
life in their goals whatever they want
to accomplish you want them to win
more than you want them to win with you
if you can start to adopt that mindset
it really starts to shift how you see
your relationships how you see your
business how do you see the people on
your team and it allows so much more
positive energy to flow in the right
direction for everybody to accomplish
their goals so quick example
I made a video I made a bunch of videos
on Tony Robbins Tony Robbins is one of
the first people that well he was I
guess the first big person who kind of
recognizes the work that I was doing and
he put the video I made on him on his
home page on YouTube and got a lot more
views and we made more videos than Tony
Robbins Tony then invites me to go to
his event we did a couple interviews
together he invites me to go and puts me
in you know the awesome seating right up
front and I got a lot of people coming
up to say hey Evan they recognize me I'm
also wearing the hoodie not that I'm a
celebrity but in that kind of world
people would recognize me and they said
you introduced me to Tony Robbins
that they found out about Tony Robbins
or Simon Simon or Tom bilyu or whoever
through the content that I'm putting up
and I had a few people who said hey I I
found out about Tony Robbins from you
and I haven't actually gone back and
watched your videos in a while because
I've been so deep in Tony Robbins land
and now I'm here at this event and paid
thousands of dollars to be here learning
from Tony
and I don't watch your channel anymore
but thank you for introducing me to Tony
Robbins because that's what I watch now
I'm pumped
I'm excited it's like that's amazing
thank you for telling me
now what I would I love for them to be
with me forever yes of course absolutely
but I'm more happy that you're off
winning if you watch this video and you
learn from Simon sinek and you've never
heard of him before you have and you
want to dive deeper and then you go and
you buy all his books and you subscribe
to him on YouTube and you dive deep into
his world and you don't come back and
watch another video of mine for another
12 months I'm I'm pumped for you I want
you to win as a human as an entrepreneur
more than I want you to subscribe to my
channel and keep watching videos here
it's just a fundamental shift in how you
see relationships I look at the people
on my team I want them all to win as
people more than win with me and I see
everybody that I'm working with as a
parallel path
you and I right now you're watching this
video we're on a parallel path this is a
parallel path that we're we're marching
on together and then at the end of this
video you're going to go off and go do
something else and hopefully productive
and empowering and impactful you're
gonna have a great day come on let's go
believe Nation but you're gonna go off
and do something else you're gonna
you're gonna step out different
Carmichael path and go do something else
and maybe you come back on the path or
maybe you go way off and you and you
never come back but right now you're
watching this video we're on a parallel
path you and I together
I just want to maximize that time
together that while you're on a path
with me that you're going to become
better and that should be your goal with
the people you're around that we have
these parallel paths that we're running
together for a certain amount of time
and maybe that's 10 minutes in a
conversation maybe that's a year of
somebody working with you maybe that's
10 years maybe that's a life partner
that's forever right but you're on these
parallel paths your goal needs to be
while somebody's interacting with you in
person via email through your content
they're with you that they're a better
person because of that interaction with
you
if you can do that if you can just
change the way you see relationships to
do that to instead just think about
yourself first and think about them
first and helping them accomplish what
they need to accomplish even if it means
leaving you I've I've recommended people
to courses and programs that are not my
own I've kicked people off of my team
because I was going to hold them back
they wanted to stay here but like you
need to go and do that thing this is too
safe and comfortable for you and I can't
give you the thing that you want
you have to leave and go do that thing
and push them towards it also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five embrace the end
embrace the end most people are thinking
or most people are thinking do I do this
or do this do I do this business or do
this business if you think about your
passions and your interests right what
do you love doing what's your heart
centered thing that you could do all day
you probably have a couple things and
you feel like you have to pick this is
the mistake people feel like you have to
pick you don't have to pick the actual
selection is in doing both of those
things combined a lot of people have
said some amazing things of me is very
humbling I think of Ed mylett and
garyvee where garyvee called me the DJ
that likes to watch so much content and
then spin it to inspire people and Ed
mylette said that I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill Napoleon Hill is the
biggest influence of all time personal
development and I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill first off that's
extremely humbling but
why are they saying that this is how I'm
unique because I love consuming all of
this stuff and I love spinning it and
mixing it up as well as adding my own
message to things this is how I'm
Different there's a lot of people who
are just sharing their message and
there's a lot of people who are also
mixing things together but there's
nobody who's really mixing things
together and sharing their own message
right so instead of looking at those two
things as different Brian's like I have
to pick I gotta pick this or this like
I'm going to combine them and that's how
I'm going to be unique so think about
your different interests what do you
love doing what are what are your top
two three things that you can get lost
in and they feel completely different
your Genius is going to be in actually
mixing those things together in a way
that's never been done before and then
usually not to bring value to people
stop thinking or and instead embrace the
end rule number six lean in on your
worry one of the things that really
helped me
was leaning into
the fact that I'm shy and introverted
and I afraid to get in front of the
camera and afraid to get on stage and no
need to be famous that's led to actually
a lot of opportunities
[Laughter]
the more I lean in on those things the
more things come to me I remember doing
a speech at Brandon burchard's growth
event and
I wasn't as myself I was more
professional I was more just given
advice great great advice people loved
it and then he invited me back to speak
at his uh private Mastermind and now
this these groups are paying 30 to 50
000 to be in that room uh so now there's
higher pressure you know like the first
one the ticket was maybe 100 bucks the
ticket to this one is thirty thousand
dollars to fifty thousand dollars like
oh my gosh extra pressure and
I just leaned in on it
I I walked up on stage and I I came
after dean grazio team so Dean spoke and
then it was me and Dean was using the
Flipboard
uh you know this is like a paper beside
you and you're you're flipping one page
at a time and I'd never used a Flipboard
in in any of my presentations I've had
PowerPoint in the past or I normally
just get up and talk but I thought okay
I'm gonna try to use the Flipboard
and I didn't know how to use it I I
always felt like I was blocking somebody
uh at some hiding behind the Flipboard
trying to write it and it ended up being
really funny and um
Brendan took me aside after and he said
that was the best that was so much
better than you did at in Arizona at my
first event and Arizona was great but
like you need to lean in on your
goofiness you need to lean in on your
shyness you need to lean in on the
things that make you nervous if you're
if you're nervous say you're nervous if
you have anxiety say you have anxiety
um I I've LED with something like that
it's like I'm I'm scared I'm an
introvert I'm shy and I've got my heart
beating like crazy right now standing up
here in front of all you guys that's how
it led my speech something like that
um and so leaning in on that has helped
has helped me it's a lot more real
yeah it's a lot more real so you don't
feel like you have to be fake you can
just lean in on the thing that makes
your heart go crazy like this lean in on
it if you were to make a video to say I
want to tell you my story
now if I go back to the landscaping
company I want to tell you why I do what
I do and normally I hate making videos
and this makes me really anxious and
nervous and I'm scared to do this but
Landscaping is just so important
it's so important to me because and then
you tell the story with the mom wouldn't
you want to hire that person wouldn't
you want to pay more for that person
right so leaning in on your story on the
thing that you're worried that you're
going to get judged for is the way that
you're gonna win rule number seven take
immediate action take some kind of
immediate action
most people's immediate action is
research
planning that's not enough immediate
action is doing you have to do something
and you don't know where to start this
is the next thing yeah I don't know
where to start I want to start a YouTube
channel I don't know where to start you
start by pulling out your phone and
making a video I'm in my car on my phone
making a video
you can too
it's not worrying about it being perfect
it's expecting to suck and just start
just create
I call the two percent differences for
like what's the first two percent on
your idea we plan to get to 100 instead
of just going and doing something on the
first two percent
whatever that big idea is
start to teach yourself that your ideas
are amazing the ideas of Flow To You are
good
they're good for you they're good for
your family they're good for your
community they're good for the world
they're good and you have a duty to
start doing something towards them start
to train yourself on this recently I
wanted to learn about nfts and
cryptocurrency and I've I've dabbled and
learned a little bit but I just decided
I'm gonna I'm gonna figure this out
and last week on Friday I spent the day
learning it and I had all sorts of
obstacles thrown in my way I couldn't
get money out of my bank account because
my bank blocked cryptocurrency purchases
my Visa blocked cryptocurrency purchases
there's a whole bunch of restrictions as
a Canadian to buy from the different
exchanges all sorts of problems all
sorts and you know what like one problem
after another after another my my U.S
bank account like well I've got a U.S
account with TD so I'm gonna go to my us
account no problem
the TD was closed the online banking had
a had a update that their website
crashed like oh my gosh it's like
non-stop but we figured it out built
some momentum started taking some kind
of action
it makes a huge huge huge huge
difference because while you're feeling
the Bold energy if you wait till
tomorrow you won't feel the energy
anymore you can have the perfect plan
but tomorrow you won't have the same
mindset and so you won't execute the
plan rule number eight get close to
customers try to get as close to
customers as possible so it's great to
be making it's big it's great to be
creative it's great to be you know
imagineering of where you could go
when you start to solve the problem for
yourself that's a great step one because
there's probably a lot of people who
currently are who you used to be and
seeing how you solved it for yourself
sharing the videos I need the videos for
myself and then I share them and it
helps other people right so I solved the
problem for me first you solve the
problem for you first I know there's
lots of people like you but you need to
start talking to customers you need to
start getting their feedback you need to
start seeing what they interact with and
that can help guide a lot of your future
product or service creation you need to
get out of just sitting by yourself on
your couch researching and into actually
talking to people so a quick example for
my channel
the whole top 10 rules for Success thing
came because I just made one video on
Kanye West that's why he's you know on
the wall behind me made one video on him
and then people started requesting more
hey can you do Dame Dash hey can you do
Jay-Z hey can you do Jeff Bezos hey can
you do Steve Jobs hey can you do these
people and
it's like well that's a cool idea sure
why not I could do that I never thought
of it as being a whole series I just was
wanted to give a tribute to Kanye West
and it was a one-off video
and then in the videos that people were
suggesting can you do this person this
person this person this person I still
get final say we ended up having over 2
000 different requests for people to
profile I still get final say as to who
we profile
because I have to feel connected to the
message and when I'm pulling out the
content if we're doing Kanye West or
Steve Jobs it's always something
positive it's always through the lens of
belief because that's what I want to put
out I don't want to put out Kanye West's
biggest attacks or insults or negativity
I want to put out negativity in the
world I could easily done top 10 top 10
Kanye West stupidest things you've ever
done I'm not interested in putting that
out
so it's that combination of what people
are asking for hey can you do this can
you do that can you do this plus what I
love doing right what I want to put my
steak in the ground to say I made this
right this is the contribution that I'm
trying to make to the world back to the
entrepreneur success formula right what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people so how to figure out what
brings value to other people you have to
get as close to the customer as possible
understand their business understand
what they're going through understand
their mindset you solving the problem
for yourself is a good first step and
then going into okay what are you
struggling with rule number nine
to mentors who you would never have
access to if you are struggling thinking
I don't have connections I don't know
anybody who's had success I don't have
any good mentors everybody talks about
mentorship and how important it is and I
don't have anybody in my life to help me
books could be that for you
books can be an accumulation of of
sometimes Decades of knowledge
all condensed down into 200 300 400
pages that you get a window into
somebody else's life and so whatever you
don't know yet whatever you want to
learn chances are it's in a book it's in
videos as well I love YouTube but it can
be in books there's no excuse not
anymore for you not to get access to the
information and be around the people
that can take you to where you want to
go I'm a big believer that you're a
product of your environment you know
think about who you're hanging out with
where you are right now where you spend
your time
what information are you feeding into
your brain the fact that you're here
watching this video is already a step up
is there already showcase that you are
an achiever and that you want more in a
life that you you don't want to stay
where you are that you don't want to be
in the same spot think about one year
from today you don't want to still be
where you are right now right you want
growth you want progress you want impact
you want to touch people's lives that's
why you're here
it just needs to be more consistent it
just needs to be more thorough you know
there's a expression of the fastest way
to learn a language is to go to the
country the fastest way to learn
Japanese to go to Japan
and if you can't actually go to Japan
then you try to make your environment as
much Japanese as possible you watch
Japanese TV you read Japanese books you
go to Japanese restaurants try to order
in Japanese you start hanging out with
Japanese people you take online Japanese
classes you watch Japanese YouTube
channels like you try to be around it as
much as possible and for too many of us
we're not doing as much you know are you
consistent in watching inspective videos
every morning I make them every morning
for you but you're probably not watching
them every morning are you consistent in
your other habits and your other
routines in the books that you're
reading and the content you're consuming
like are you consistent enough and
that's usually the problem
is that you have these moments where
you're bold and you're ambitious and
like I'm tired of this life and I want
to do better and this is the day and so
you have the energy and motivation and
you go off and do the thing but then
tomorrow you wake up and it's just not
there anymore and you don't stay
consistent on the habit
and the only difference between the
people who've had tons of success and
and where you're at right now is that
they just kept doing it they just stayed
consistent on the habit and so
if you look at reading as an example I
used to read a ton
before YouTube came out before videos
I'm a visual learner I'd much rather
watch something than than read it but
there was no YouTube there were no real
videos to learn from so I started with
books and now I've come back to books a
little bit where I'm I'm trying to read
10 pages a day so the goal is 10 pages a
day and I've been
95 consistent on hitting 10 pages a day
rule number 10 the last one before our
scary things everyone tells you to think
bigger to dream bigger to 10x your goals
to if you had a million dollars or a
billion dollars what would you do
I think the bigger problem is not that
you can't come up with a bigger vision
for yourself it's the belief that it's
possible that's why I think that lack of
belief is the world's number one problem
for me for for you for all your Heroes
and gurus all of them the lack of belief
in the next thing in your big vision is
the reason why you're not following
through and being consistent on it
especially for Achievers you guys
entrepreneurs you're watching this video
you have big Visions you know if we gave
you the challenge of what is your big
goal what is your big Vision what is the
life you want to create we can get lost
in the exercises right and that Clarity
is power right sitting down and writing
down your goals and where do you want to
become and where are you going to be in
five years and all of those things can
be great exercises to get you started to
get you thinking and while we're writing
it down here's what happens while you're
writing it down you actually feel that
it's possible
you've let go of the limitations you've
let go of the restrictions you've let go
of your environment and your situation
said this is what I want to create and
in that moment of boldness you feel like
everything is possible
and then what happens very quickly
afterwards maybe it's 10 minutes after
maybe it's an hour after maybe it's the
next day maybe it even lasts a week you
start to look at that list of where
you're going to be and you think wow I
can't I can't do that right does it
sound familiar have you ever set some
giant goal for yourself feeling bold
motivated and then the next day you wake
up I I can't do that I'm crazy I was
crazy it's not even you telling your
your friends or your family your social
media it's you telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it right that's
the inner game that we need to work on
so how do we start to fix it one
I think it starts with understanding
that the ideas that you come up with
when you're feeling bold powerful
inspired motivated are actually the
right ones for you when you're feeling
bold and you come up with something and
maybe that's because you watched a video
or had a good conversation or read a
book or went to a conference or event
you're for whatever reason you've
stepped outside your current mindset
limitations belief system you've stepped
outside you're you're looking at you
yeah you look at a more confident more
bold version of you
and you come up with an idea that you
want to do that I believe is actually
the best thing for you and then your
head starts talking you down because
someone like you can't do it be safe be
practical there's no way you can
accomplish it you don't have the money
resources education support system
Etc whatever whatever valid you know
these aren't made up excuses these are
valid excuses valid reasons they make
sense otherwise you wouldn't believe
them
but that's your job to still go off and
do that scary thing Step One is when
you're feeling that boldness and you
come up with an idea understand that
that's actually the best you talking
that's actually the thing you have to go
off and do you have to start building
some momentum towards and your brain
will forever try to keep you small
this is the challenge that we're not
consistent because we don't believe that
we can do the things that we say that we
want to do
there is one practice
that if you can learn to consistently
Implement in your business
it'll change the entire direction it'll
it'll allow you to accomplish
crazy goals that you never thought were
possible and that is to make data driven
decisions
it sounds super boring for any of the
heart LED passion driven type A
personality entrepreneurs out there
watching looking at data and looking at
numbers and looking at spreadsheets
might be the most boring thing in the
world for you but when the data is
coming from your customers the people
consuming your content the people who
you're ultimately selling to and you get
insights into them it can make a
dramatic shift
and how you see your business how you
operate your company and how much money
you start to make I'm a big believer
that you make the big decisions in life
with the heart with the heart and the
small ones with the head big decisions
with the heart small ones with the head
the heart is why do you do what you do
why have you started this business why
is it so important to you what is the
mission you're trying to solve right so
for me I want to solve the world's
biggest problem I want people to believe
in themselves more that's the heart
there's no science attached to it it's
just hard it's just art the heart is Art
right it's creation and I love tapping
into that side
and then the small decisions with the
head in that
the things that I do have to work
otherwise I just have a hobby right if
you're only doing art and it has no
value to other people you're not talking
to customers you're not engaging
reactions you're not seeing how you can
get better then you just have a hobby
that doesn't pay you right which can be
fulfilling not everything has to pay you
but if the goal is to have a business
then yeah you have to get paid otherwise
you don't have a company for very long
if you're only listening to the customer
data and you're only looking for
opportunities but you don't actually
like the thing then you're also going to
lose right because you're just chasing
domain but you're not curious enough
about you don't care enough about it you
don't have enough heart for it example
in my business if I were to make the top
10 stupidest things X person has ever
said that that data wise would blow up
because people would rather consume
negativity and poke fun at somebody and
try to tear somebody down than to learn
and try to improve their own life in
general it's so much easier to to laugh
and poke fun at somebody else and
criticize somebody else instead of
working on ourselves to become better
right entertainment versus education
entertainment is a lot easier to consume
than education because it requires more
work on your part
so I could do that and the data would
say hey go make these videos they will
do better but it doesn't match my heart
I don't want to do that
so the heart gets the veto power but you
have to still listen to the brain right
so big decisions with the heart small
ones with the brain
so let's bring it back to data-driven
decisions
a lot of people struggle with it because
they don't know how to make data-driven
decisions they don't know what numbers
to look at they don't know how to
collect the information they get quite
frankly bored of looking at the
information the data
and so then they make subjective
opinions
and often make the wrong ones yesterday
I'm on a call with a team of a somebody
super well known
huge presence you you know you would
know his name you've heard it inside out
I've profiled him millions of times you
know on my own channel
uh that kind of narrows it down but I'm
not going to tell you who
so I'm on the call with his team and
we're looking at some of his YouTube
videos and the goal is to reach even
more people on YouTube great so we
looked at one of the thumbnails and his
team said well he picked this thumbnail
like yeah but this thumbnail it's it's
just not going to work like this
thumbnail sucks I'm a best practice from
everything I've seen from doing 12 000
split tests on YouTube thumbnails like
this is
with a very high degree of certainty not
a good thumbnail in terms of getting
impact
getting more people to click on it
getting more people to view it
and the team said yeah but he picked
that thumbnail
I agree with you Evan I don't like it
either but he picked that thumbnail
okay well here's how you combat that
situation what is his ultimate goal his
ultimate goal is to have more impact his
ultimate goal is to reach more people
right probably let's you know make sure
we get that right you know if his if his
mom on her deathbed said you have to use
this as my thumbnail okay you know great
there's a there's a reason other than
business for picking that thumbnail but
if the goal of this video if we can
agree that the goal of this video is to
try to reach as many people as possible
to spread your message as wide as
possible yes perfect let me help you do
that the challenge becomes it's one
person's subjective opinion against
another's and the person who's in charge
is almost always going to win that fight
right if the person who's at the top
says I want this and then somebody
underneath says but I think this would
be better
and there's no data to support anything
it's just one subjective opinion against
another the person at the top usually
wins so I said okay here's what you do
you agree that the goal is to get as
many views as on the video as possible
in an ethical honest way we're not
clickbaiting we're not doing something
against the brand
let's split test it
so here's what you want to do here's an
idea that I've got let's split test it
for two weeks and see what happens
and what I've always found is that
people will listen to the data when they
feel like you're on the same page when
they feel like you're fighting for the
same goal as them because if you can
then show him that hey this video this
is the case that you bring
this video
if I change the thumbnail did twice as
bad twice as good right it does twice as
the two x's twice better whatever
doubles the impact right if you could
bring by changing just a thumbnail same
video by changing the thumbnail
you can get twice as many views here's
the data to show you not just my
subjective opinion but here's the data
to show you here's yours here's what it
did here's the one that we tried for two
weeks just let me try for two weeks
here's what we tried for two weeks
double the views
double the impact
what do you prefer you tell me what's
more important do you still want to go
with that because it again you should
have some other reason for it and and
this isn't said in a condescending way
it's like hey help me understand this
thumbnail that we tried
double the performance which one do you
want to go with and they always go with
the one that gets better results the
challenge is when you're bringing the
idea
it's just your opinion
and they will almost always trust their
opinion over your opinion until you come
with the data the first is lean in on
service that I'm here to serve I'm here
to help I'm trying to do something of
good what's the intention behind this
thing you're about to do if you're going
to go on stage or you're going to make a
video you're going to make a video walk
into the park right what's the intention
is the intention to hurt somebody to
screw somebody over to lie to them to
cheat no hopefully not not if you're a
fan of this channel come on now the
intention is good the intention is
positive you wanna you wanna serve you
want to help you want your message to
hopefully impact somebody's life if
you're selling a product or service yes
you want to make money and you're trying
to solve a problem you're trying to help
people so anytime I make it about you
you know the people watching it I make
it personal I focus on service instead
of focusing on me how am I received
however how are you liking me how is
that guy who passed by what is he
thinking about me right when that's
that's about me I'm worried about me I'm
in my own head I'm playing small anytime
I can focus on other people and the
value that they're hopefully going to
get at least with the intention I
wouldn't be uh maybe so bold or Brave to
say no this is going to be my best video
ever but it's my intention always it's
my intention to try to make the best
video I've ever done and and give as
much value as I can and to serve and
hopefully one person is touched by this
video and it means something to them
right so when you're afraid to do
something
focus in on service reminding yourself
every day of how amazing you are I think
it's one of the greatest gifts you can
give yourself and it's not about ego
it's about confidence confidence comes
from a place of strength ego comes from
a place of weakness and insecurity so
it's time to step into your confidence
and remind yourself of how amazing you
really are this video is gonna help so I
used to have a lot of problems with with
ego versus confidence I used to feel
like who am I why do people need to hear
my story I was profiling all these
different successful entrepreneurs and
people kept asking well where are you
how come we can't see what you're about
where did you come from and I always
felt like my story doesn't matter I'm
profiling David Goggins and Steve Jobs
and and all these people why do you care
about I mean sure I sold my first
business had an exit but it's nothing
compared to what all these other people
have done and I always
shrouded it covered it under ego like
well that's such an egotistical thing to
do
but really I was just playing small I
was cheating people the opportunity to
learn to get better to grow from my
story that my story has value it's the
belief that my story had value that took
some time to really work up even making
videos on my channel the number one most
requested person for top 10 was me and I
resisted for maybe two years of even
making an Evan Carmichael top 10 because
I just felt not good enough I felt like
that's such an ego play and not coming
from a place of confidence and yes my
message has impact has meaning can help
the world and the first urban Carmichael
top 10 came out from my team so my
birthday birthday I think it was my
birthday birthday or Christmas my team
put together with the with the support
of my hardcore fans my first top 10.
you wanna watch it I'm a little scared
and that's the one that that went live
on the channel and ever since then we've
done a regular series of me being on the
channel but it's it's been a real
progress for me it's been a real
Evolution it's taken me a long time and
hopefully you can get there faster this
has been almost 20 years of me sharing
ideas and content and and slowly
stepping into the light and slowly
building more confidence and more belief
and I hope that
with the content I'm making and the
experiences I'm sharing you can get
there a lot faster the world's biggest
problem is a lack of belief the biggest
problem for me for you for Brandon
burchard for everybody is a lack of
belief you believe in yourself to the
extent of what you've done that you can
do it again but you don't believe in The
Next Step you don't believe that you can
go from here to here this is why I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something like you're a
genius you are the best in the world at
something and it's not what you what you
went to school for it's not what your
parents taught you it's not what the
people around you are doing is probably
something very very very different and
unlike your parents or grandparents it's
actually possible now because of
Technology because of the Internet it's
actually possible for you to go off and
be this Michael Jordan level genius at
something you don't need to have the
resources you don't need to have the
education you don't need to have the
connection because it's all the walls
have been broken down and it's only
getting easier
but it's still the lack of belief in the
ability to do the thing
people say well I think cancer is the
world's biggest problem great I think
cancer should have been solved by now
the woman who would have solved cancer
is a manager at an accounting firm doing
work that she hates because one she
never believes in herself enough to go
down the
route to become a doctor or researcher
and two even if she started she didn't
believe in herself enough that she could
be the genius at it the Michael Jordan
level genius best in the world or
something and this is this is what
happens we settle we get stuck we get
complacent we we find all these reasons
and excuses why we can't do it we're
really it's just fear and lack of belief
and every time you break through every
every major breakthrough that I've had
in my life has come on the other side of
me believing in myself more that I could
go up and do that thing you
goes as fuel and I add this in not
because I use it but because I know it
works for a lot of other people and and
I'm channeling Tom bill you right now
this is one of the things that Tom does
that's he credits to having his success
if you know Tom impact Theory built a
billion dollar business with with Quest
and now has this awesome YouTube channel
he has a list he has a list of all the
people who doubted him who didn't
believe in him and whenever he feels
like he really needs that extra
motivation he goes to that dark place
and looks at that list and say all these
people did not believe in me I'm gonna
show them wrong I don't do that I don't
get a lot of power strength for myself
of being in the dark side approving
somebody wrong but
I think it can be very beneficial for
people and a lot of people do talk about
it so I wanted to at least give that to
you as an option use those no's as fuel
use that your mom telling you that you
suck and you can't make it maybe she
doesn't say that you suck but that you
can't make it using your friends or
haters online saying that you're never
gonna do it using that as fuel to say
I'm gonna show you and prove you wrong I
just think the danger is if you live in
there for too long if you're only fueled
for the dark side it consumes you if
you're only doing something to prove
somebody wrong you're never going to
stay consistent persistent enough
because it's not a good enough reason at
the core of doing the thing has to be
you love doing a thing you want to serve
right you're built to serve you want to
serve you want to help you want to help
right but if you have to channel the
dark side every now and then use those
noses fuel to help you get forward then
go for it and give it a shot your
actions have to map to your Ambitions
one of the biggest challenges people
have is figuring out what does balance
look like for you you don't want to have
Jeff bezos's calendar you don't want to
have Evan Carmichael's calendar either
balance looks like something different
to us finding your version of balance
mapping your actions to your Ambitions
and then Having the courage and the
confidence to chase that down and apply
it to your life when the people around
you are saying you're nuts you're crazy
that's the juice of life that is where
you'll find peace as well as your
success so as an example let me walk you
through a typical week in the life of
Evan Carmichael
having my morning routine that I do
pretty much every day of the week I have
my evening routine that I'll do pretty
much every day of the week and then I
have different days for different things
I find that if I have one full day to
focus on just one main task I'm much
more productive so on Mondays is my
mentoring day and I'm spending the whole
day mentoring the people on my team
we're growing we've got over 25 people
on the team and some people I talk to
every week some people every month some
people every quarter but I spend the
whole day just figuring out how can I
make the people on my team better listen
to her improved training skills all of
it that's my whole day on Monday and all
I'm doing is being in the mentoring Zone
Tuesday is my YouTube day I'm making
videos I'm strategizing I'm planning I'm
creating I'm all in on just making
YouTube videos my team doesn't bother me
on Tuesdays unless it's an urgent
emergency they're not connecting with me
on Tuesday because I'm in YouTube mode
Wednesday is my project day I work on
the things that I want to do to grow my
business whatever project is on my mind
right now so right now build to serve
right getting the book out promoting it
uh working on my email campaigns and
sequences and finals and all of that is
most of Wednesdays Thursdays is my
public facing day that's what I'm doing
interviews and hangouts and podcasts and
being on people's Instagram shows and
YouTube shows and radio shows it's all
day it's it's 25 minutes on five minute
break 25 minutes on five minute break my
entire Thursday Fridays is my CEO day
and so I'm doing bigger picture projects
to help build my business and grow it
forward so day becomes fun day Saturday
is when I spend the day with my wife
normally
I'm planning a new food place for us to
go eat and looking at festivals for us
to go to and enjoy uh we're in
coronavirus time right now so we're in
lockdown but it's basically non-work day
and I'm in charge of planning a day for
myself my wife to have a fun day that I
know she's going to enjoy Sunday's
family at midday and that's when we're
doing Costco and dishes and laundry and
we'll do the dishes more than just
Sunday laundry and clean up the condo
and going to Home Depot or whatever has
to get done that's more kind of on the
admin side and when you have clearly
defined days for for your life at least
for my life it prevents bleed so for
example if you know we really have to go
to Costco to get something not on a
Saturday nope you have to defend your
time you got to defend your time because
other things will constantly attack in
your time if you're ever at the point
where you feel like everybody has
something for you to do and you have no
time for yourself it's it's your fault
you haven't put the boundaries up you
haven't put the gates up you haven't
protected your time enough with the
shield that you have that's what you
need to do on a consistent basis and say
I love you I respect you I want to help
you I want to work with you this is my
time
I can help you over here
and and the cavities when you show up
for them you're with them act on your
uncomfortable ideas we get great ideas
as entrepreneurs we get great ideas and
especially moments of boldness and
confidence and courage you get great
ideas it could be when you're in a
shower on an airplane or traveling you
get great ideas for what you want to do
and then tomorrow you tell yourself ah I
can't do that that's crazy that that's
too hard that's that's scary that's
uncomfortable
teach yourself to act on your crazy
ideas is how you start to build
confidence because if you come up
against a crazy idea and then you allow
yourself to say well that's too scary
that's too hard that's too difficult I
can't do that what you've taught
yourself is you don't have courage
you've taught yourself to come up with
ideas but then not trust in yourself and
so when you come up with the next idea
you're telling yourself I don't trust
myself when you set a goal for yourself
to hit hit some Big Goal you don't
believe yourself anymore because all
you've done is taught yourself that you
set goals you have ideas and you never
follow through you've built this
identity of I'm somebody who doesn't
follow through that's what you need to
start to destroy
that's where you need to destroy and
squash out of your life that identity of
I don't follow through your ideas are
genius your ideas are amazing this is
why play bigger truth and help you get
an idea and you're in your awesome
environment act on it do something lean
into the uncomfortable lean into the
things that cause a little bit of your
heart to beat and cause some anxiety
that's how you start to make the shift
deciding your top three goals right now
what are your top three goals most
important things to you right now what
are your priorities the three big things
that have to happen for you what are
they get clear get specific if you don't
know what they are that's why you're not
chasing anything big down
if you even thought about it then then
that's the problem you're stuck in these
small projects for Life what are your
three big goals for your business and
your life right now staying in your
cocoon and only hanging around the same
five to ten people if those people are
not more ambitious than you then you're
gonna stay stuck you're gonna feel good
about yourself because you're pushing
everybody and you're optimistic and and
you feel good relative to where they're
at but you won't be growing you you are
probably the most ambitious person that
you know you're the you're the most
positive most uplifting most energetic
most ambitious person of any of the
people that you hang out with and that's
great and fulfilling and you can serve
them and help them but it limits your
own growth
you stay stuck and you stay super slow
growing and so you need to inject people
who have a greater belief system than
you into your life to make you feel like
you can grow and continue to get better
and that could be somebody who's
actually in your life quick like side
note if there's anybody in your life
at all who you've met once twice four
times right it doesn't have to be your
family somebody that you've hung out
with and met that made you feel better
about yourself when you left them holy
cow hang on to that person I love the
what I say collect good people hang on
to those people find a way to to do a
business with them find a way to spend
time with them find a way to to hang out
with them but Brandon burchard reaching
out to me to do this business together
right like he's finding ways to hang out
with what he thinks is good people so
you know that's that's a tremendous
Honor on my part
so if you have anybody like that and
again it's probably not the closest
people to you you have to go on The
Fringe of people you have spent some
time with try to spend more time with
them find the reason to do it whether
it's starting the business together
whether it's just having a monthly
coffee together just to connect again do
it
if you don't have anybody like that in
your life don't stress that's why
there's videos that's why there's books
that's why there's podcasts if you
watched if you actually started your day
with an espresso video every day your
life will start to shift you won't
notice it tomorrow or the next day or
the next day but a month later three
months later six months later you start
to see I'm I'm thinking bigger now I'm
I'm more bold I'm more confident I I
want to do bigger things with my life
well why is that it's because you're
hanging around people who are doing
bigger things with their life even
virtually so I can learn a lot from
Brendan who I've met and now doing a
partnership with but also from Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and all these
people the more I'm around them the more
they pull me to want to think bigger
focus on progress when you focus on
progress instead of the end result
that's where I think you can keep your
motivation and keep your belief when I
first started making my videos I wasn't
getting any results right nobody was
watching nobody was commenting I felt
like a loser right like nobody cares
it's not happening I'm not getting the
results understand that you very rarely
ever get results at the beginning if you
focus on just getting the results at the
beginning you're likely going to get too
discouraged and quit it's not that the
results aren't important it's just
people have a Too Short an attention
span and when you focused on the results
at the beginning it is too discouraging
and you do give up instead you focus on
the progress are you getting better are
you learning was your video better than
last time did you show up with more
energy than last time did you have
better points than you did last time was
that sales call you did better than the
one last time was your next test better
than it was yesterday right are you
getting better because if you can say
I'm getting better if you if you're
making videos and you look back a week
later a month later and said man I still
suck but I'm better than I was
a week ago a month ago and you can focus
on the progress at least for me it
really helps fuel my motivation my
belief in myself that hey if I made that
growth from here to here then I can make
more growth from here to here
and at the beginning here's the thing at
the beginning the growth is pretty fast
when you're learning something from from
scratch at the beginning you actually
learn very quickly
it's at the end that it gets harder
for me right now to keep getting better
is harder I don't see as big a return on
my on my progress as Evan Chronicle
growth from last week to this week from
last month to this month how much better
am I on camera from last month to this
month not that much
it requires even more effort and even
more mentorship and even when practicing
training to get better as when you're
close to the top
at the beginning you can learn really
quickly and there's a lot of progress
the flip side for me now is lots of
results right when you start actually
getting good that's when the results
kick in
so then you can start focusing on the
result so hey is this working or not is
this video doing better than the last
one or not because you start getting
some data and results to work with
so at the beginning you're focusing on
the progress am I getting better am I
improving and am I learning is it better
than I was last week and then as that
starts to taper off you might get
frustrated with your progress but good
news
you're going to start seeing results
come in and that'll keep you motivated
to keep going as well don't compromise
is an amazing message but too many of
you who are perfectionists will hear
that message and use it as an excuse for
not taking action I'm a firm believer
that planners need to do more and doers
need to plan more and here's the problem
planners do not need to plan more you're
already great at planning you will plan
and plan plan plan plan your life away
and never actually take any kind of
action and so for the perfectionists out
there for the planners who want to have
the perfect Plan before you do anything
this is an amazing message but you're
not hearing it correctly it's not don't
compromise on having the perfect plan
and just sit in your room all day and
don't take any action because Steve Jobs
was a doer
this is a hard lesson that I had to
learn myself because I lost a 40 million
dollar deal in my first business when I
was 21 22.
because I was a perfectionist because
everything had to be perfect because I
didn't want to compromise that's how I
interpreted the message but as a result
I didn't do anything and just kept
planning and I lost the deal became
between us and our biggest competitor
and we were really late to the party
because we didn't do the right thing and
we ended up losing the deal
now would we have won it if I had done
more maybe not 100 but I would have had
a better shot at it and so ever since
then I've been trying to release that
perfectionist habit it's still in there
I still love the plane but the people
have the most success have that
combination of planning but then
actually doing block the time and take
small losses for big wins physically put
into your calendar
this block of time on Monday afternoon
I'm spending on XYZ and I am okay with
losing some small losses I will not be
reachable I might lose a deal there
might be some burn down happening that I
can't take charge of I'm going to
disappoint somebody I'm going to let
somebody down not with not with
intentionally not on purpose
but it's gonna happen and you're not
going to kick yourself for doing it
because what you're going to make you're
going to make that time count those two
hours four hours six hours eight hours
however long you're spending working on
your goals you're gonna make that time
count
you're sacrificing all these small wins
that you love going after to make this
time count
so use that as pressure
not to feel guilty about yourself for
not doing those little small wins and
being linked getting back to people but
in saying I am working on something
that's going to change my life
and because of these people who are
depending on me for everything else and
I'm pushing that off I better make this
time count use that pressure to drive
you forwards instead of backwards
planning doesn't count
planning strategizing making ideas that
doesn't count where you're going to grow
doesn't count you got to do you got to
send an email you got to make a piece of
content you got to post something you
gotta follow up with somebody you have
to create you got to make instead of
just living in your head right that's
how you tell the difference plan is just
living in your head model structured
business plans ideas it's it's amazing I
love it I could be there all day long
but you won't have any kind of impact
just staying up in here do
every single day adopt the mindset that
you need to do on a daily basis you have
Michael Jordan level genius at something
you you you are the greatest the
greatest in the world at something and
it's probably not what your parents did
or what you went to school for it's
sitting here somewhere deep buried and
you don't believe that you can do it
but until you actually lean in on what
you have Michael Jordan ability genius
at until you actually start doing it
you'll never live the life that you're
capable of you'll you'll constantly be
doing
what other people want you to do living
up to other people's expectations
meanwhile knowing that you're capable of
more I got into fights uh maybe not
fights discussions maybe arguments with
people about when they're making YouTube
videos for example thought leaders I'm
I'm deeply passionate about helping more
thought leaders get onto YouTube I want
to see your message out there because I
believe that your message can change the
world I think your message can impact
people's lives of people like you who
you used to be they need to hear your
message and you're you're too scared to
get it up there and one of the biggest
complaints are one of the biggest
objections people have is well I don't
know how to edit I don't know how to
film and what they end up doing is you
spend 20 minutes making a video
recording it and then five hours editing
it
what you're doing there is training the
wrong skill
if you want to make a video like this
right
you're gonna sit in your car I'm still
just making this video off of my
mind like I've just got a little mini
handheld whatever tripod I guess
a selfie stick more like it and in my
phone that's how I'm filming this video
that's it sitting here in the car while
my wife is in Costco shopping and
getting some awesome food for us
if you spend 20 minutes making a video
filming it recording it and then five
hours editing it
you're just training the wrong skill
you'll never get great at the thing that
you have Michael Jordan lovability at
now if you said your ambition is to be
the world's greatest editor that's
different congratulations you're doing
it you're doing it but if you want to be
a thought leader a speaker an expert you
want to you want to learn to make videos
and be the front facing person then
spending 20 minutes on something to
actually improve your skill that's
improving your skill making the video
but five hours editing it you just
not wasting time but you're you're
stealing from your opportunity you're
stealing from your ability you're
stealing from your best self
okay well what do I do Evan what how do
I how do I then create I don't want to
put up something that's bad
the thing that gets you there is
actually getting great at your skill the
Michael Jordan level skill
I'd rather you spend five hours
making a video doing it again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again so you don't need editing
that you're so good at the thing that
you don't need editing
because that's a skill that will serve
you for life because when you go on
stage you don't get to edit yourself
right there's no second takes when you
go on TV and you're being interviewed
when you go on people's podcasts you're
being interviewed if you you're teaching
yourself that you're only good when
you're edited and that's not your
Michael Jordan level ability this whole
seriousness versus playful thing I agree
that it's important to be playful I
think smiling is great I think having a
happy optimistic positive way of
thinking about things is really
important especially as entrepreneurs
because we have to deal with so much
crap and so much pain so much misery so
much rejection so much other people's
negativity around us that if you are not
playful if you are not joyous then it's
really really hard to keep going on your
mission and it's ultimately why a lot of
people stop and they quit they get
consumed by the negativity and they have
to leave it and go off and do something
else that being said I also think
there's a time for seriousness I think
it can really help you I think it can
help Focus you I think it can help drive
you forward on your mission the way I
see playfulness and seriousness are two
sides of the same coin I think you need
both I think they're not opposite of
each other I think they complement each
other I see it as the same thing as
ambition and gratitude I think you need
to be really ambitious I think it's
important to have big goals and set a
life for yourself that you want to go
off and accomplish and keep striving to
do it and I think it's important to be
really grateful for everything that you
already do have you are spoiled you are
lucky you are so fortunate just to be
alive just to be living in your country
just be able to watch these YouTube
videos there's so much that you have to
be grateful for that you don't even
recognize and so I think both of those
serve each other I think if you are just
overly ambitious and never are grateful
I think it just leads to a really dark
place I think it's never enough and it
just becomes all-consuming and I think
if you're only grateful all the time and
have zero ambition then that's a happy
life but you're not helping others
you're not serving others you're not
fulfilling the potential that you have
inside yourself and so I think of them
as both being necessary I think you need
both of them I think one Standalone
doesn't help you get to where you need
to go and so I see that as the same
thing as playfulness and seriousness I
see them as two sides of the same coin I
think you need both of them at different
times to help you go off and be that
best version of yourself you start
thinking about okay I'm not great at
these things
but they need to get done
right some of these things have to get
done first you want to eliminate if it's
if you don't have to do it then don't do
it this there's some things that you're
doing that actually don't matter there's
something that I'm doing that don't
matter that you think matter but then
when you analyze like that doesn't even
matter nobody even cares if I do that
thing or not
right just eliminate it don't don't give
it to somebody else if it shouldn't even
be done in the first place you eliminate
it
then you automate it so automate is look
for ways to do it through software
through technology through tools
anything that I'm I'm doing multiple
times like okay how do I how do I make
this more automatic so that I don't have
to be doing this all the time
and if you can't illuminate it and you
can't automate it then you delegate it
and delegate is you give it to somebody
give it to somebody who that's their
Michael Jordan level genius
editing these videos I have an amazing
team you know Christina hi Christina is
amazing and that's her Michael Jordan
level genius she makes amazing videos
she can edit way way way better than I
ever could let alone than what I can do
right now
and when you find people who they are
the Michael Jordan level of the thing
that you suck at that's when you can
really start to explode now you might be
you might not be able to afford them yet
so what can you do well one you get
uh people who can volunteer who can
maybe do some kind of barter like
entrepreneurship is about being
resourceful
what can you offer them and what can
they offer you what kind of trade can
you make if you have no money what kind
of trade can you make instead of saying
well I just I don't have money to hire
somebody so I'm just going to do it
myself you have to start being more
strategic
you have to start thinking okay what am
I what am I so fantastic at what is your
Michael Jordan level ability and how can
that be of value to somebody else that
in exchange for me helping them they can
help me with this thing
that's how entrepreneurship works
the ones who really really win they're
not the ones who do it all themselves
they're the ones who are resourceful to
find ways to bring on a team
right the ones who are Ultra successful
number two schedule your due time what I
want you to do is plan for one hour
every single day if you're an
entrepreneur one hour every day where
you were doing pick a time ideally I
think morning like if you get in at nine
to nine to ten first hour of the day but
if it's not then block in the account
this is important this is what will
change your life this is what will
change the trajectory of your business
if you are stuck constantly and just
responding to people and plain planning
perfectionist mode due time right we
said do a daily point number one now you
got to schedule it in just have an
intention won't do anything if you're
not actually taking action on it right
you're not doing the thing that you
promised to do you're not doing the
doing the progress that you will make
the closer you get to your goals will be
a reflection of what you are putting in
your calendar what you're actually doing
so I want you to schedule one hour today
of due time every single day we're going
to be making something and pushing it up
to the world you can't feel grateful and
sad at the same time you can't feel
grateful and upset at the same time you
can't at the same time feel grateful and
hurt
vengeful rage you can't gratitude is the
opposite emotion the opposite expression
of all of those things so whenever
you're feeling low down negative hurt
upset the answer is gratitude
I don't like staying in
negative emotions for too long the only
one is grief you know I think the only
one that I
let happen is grief because I think you
just have to work your way through it I
don't want to trick myself out of grief
because
you're feeling it for a reason I don't
actually think it's a negative emotion I
think you have to just work your way
through it but everything else upset
anger hurt jealousy rage think about all
the other negative emotions that you
experience I don't want to stain them
for too long they don't serve me they
don't serve you they don't allow you to
show up as your best self and so the
fastest way out is gratitude because
there's always something that you can't
be grateful for it's just a perspective
shift if I was sitting here in the car
feeling upset or feeling sorry for
myself or down on myself uh I can always
think back to man I used to make 300
bucks a month and feel like I wasn't
doing anything
that I was bringing no value that I
wasn't contributing to anything
and now I get the I get to sit in this
car I get to sit in this car
right that little shift can make all the
world of difference I was talking to
Jeremy yesterday on my team and Jeremy
is an entrepreneur invested into
what 18 months ago I guess he used to
have a job working at a grocery store
hating his life knowing who's capable of
more earning minimum wage
and just not liking what he was doing at
all and now he's he's built over half a
million dollar business a year
doing YouTube Consulting based off of
what I teach them teach them taught him
taught him and continue to teach him you
know he's got a half a million dollar
plus business now and we're talking
yesterday and it was a little down
because
you know there's a client who left him
and and that happens right any client
service business you get bad news
clients believe you you will at some
point underperform you will disappoint
people that's gonna happen and that and
my job is to help give more perspective
to say dude
it's okay you're still great
look at what you've built in the past
the 18 months look at where you were it
used to be a grocery store clerk now
you're working with amazing people
helping them build their channels
getting paid insane amounts of money
compared to what you're used to like how
much money do you have in your bank
account compared to where you were 18
months ago how much more fulfilled are
you in the work that you're doing right
now compared to where you used to be 18
months ago right how much of your world
has changed so don't get too down
because the down doesn't serve you most
people can't handle radical honesty we
can't handle it because we're too caught
up in other people's opinions we care
too much about what other people think
about us we're so insecure that if you
actually got honest feedback you'd feel
like
you suck as a human not that you just
have an area that you need to work on we
can't separate between
skills that we need to work on and us
the fact that we suck at a skill we
interpret as we suck as a human because
we care too much about other people
think which is why radical honesty is
not something that we generally lead
with but until you get to the point
where you can have that both with
yourself and at least with the closest
people around you until you get there
you won't have fulfilling deep
meaningful honest relationships when I
think about radical honesty I think
about it in two ways one of giving it
being able to give honest feedback and
then be able to receive it two different
sides of the coin that I'm going to
break down on this video so in terms of
giving it we would love to be able to
give more honesty back right how many
people in your life would you love to
have a more honest conversation with and
tell them what's really on your mind you
don't because you're afraid of how
they're going to react you're afraid
that they're gonna
get hurt they're gonna freak out they're
going to judge you more they're gonna
they're gonna run away whatever you're
afraid you're afraid of the reaction and
so the way around that is to show love
when you give honest feedback to
somebody the initial reaction is
negative because they feel judged
that's really at the core of it like
they feel that you are judging them they
don't feel the love so you have to Lead
With Love
the more that they feel loved that then
you give the feedback they know it's
coming from a loving place they're much
more receptive get used to releasing
imperfect things it doesn't mean that
you settle for crap
that's not the message it's not just
okay this sucks so we're going to
release it not care about it anymore by
releasing the perfect things though and
then tweaking it and getting better you
are getting used to doing you're getting
used to not just holding on to your
perfect Concepts and perfect dreams
forever for me an example could be to
make make imperfect videos you know do
Instagram stories and if I make a
mistake I post it if I make a mistake I
try to make it into something fun when I
was in Boston I was trying to say we're
going to go see some dim sum we're going
to a dim sum restaurant and say we're
going to go to dim them dim sum right I
stumbled on my words and I made into
something fun and I released it like yes
that's the best put that out there
perfectionists need to get used to
losing the perfectionist habit and it
won't ever go away that's always the
it's always the big fear that I don't
want to become a slob I don't want to
let myself go I don't want to release
garbage out to the you won't you'll
never be that person you'll never stop
caring
but you just need to lose the
perfectionist habit a little bit
because you will never be perfect
the stuff you release will never be
perfect you will always look back at
what you made and say it could be made
better and that's awesome that's your
greatest strength but it's also your
greatest vulnerability it's your
greatest weakness so getting used to
once a week releasing something that
isn't perfect
it's the best that you could make within
the time allotted
once a week every week release that
within your own industry so for me be
making a video do a Snapchat story for
me it's daily three to five times a day
but at least once a week and when it
sucks when you made a mistake when you
want to delete it when you want to say
of course they can't post that I can't
sell that I can't put that out there as
soon as you're about to hit the delete
button boom that's when you post it and
feel the fear and the nervousness and
the craziness and like oh my gosh I
can't believe I just did that that
sucked and then release it
so you know what that wasn't actually
that bad like what's the response it's
not it's not actually that bad and when
you can get used to releasing imperfect
products and keep your drive to make
perfect products that's when ultimately
you will win to move from planning mode
into the doer mode people will not
understand what you're trying to do if
you are an entrepreneur with a big dream
a big mission a big Vision some big
goals for yourself
people won't understand
what you're trying to do if everybody
understands you're thinking way too
small if everybody's like yeah that
makes a lot of sense yeah oh that that's
exactly like this you're thinking too
small your potential your vision is
bigger than how you're explaining it
at the beginning it should be difficult
for people to wrap their head around
what you do it should be difficult to
explain who you are if somebody asks you
at a networking event or some party hey
what do you do I think it should be
difficult for you to explain who you are
I think that's fantastic I think that
means you're actually living your life
instead of living inside some box that
is easy to understand I look at my
history and I've been on YouTube since
2009 my first video and at the time
YouTube was not what it is today it was
not an educational platform there
weren't really people doing entrepreneur
videos
educational videos long form videos as
you said totally different beast and it
took five years to get the 7 000
subscribers on my main channel five
years seven thousand subscribers
I remember one of the videos that
I loved the most
I was so proud I spent the most amount
of effort and collaboration time in
creating this video
and it was it was a long video it was
six minutes
six minute video back in the day so this
is long video and I showed it to
somebody when I was basically ready to
release it I showed it to somebody who
was in the industry who was not in the
YouTube industry but in the end of video
industry and
I showed it to him and I said hey what
do you think like I'm I'm pretty happy
with this video do you have any thoughts
feedback suggestions and he just didn't
want me to publish it he said nobody's
going to watch a video that's six
minutes long nobody but just it's just
way too long nobody's gonna watch it he
told me that I didn't understand how the
internet worked
and just I don't know just poured into
me I shared some of the exact quotes in
in year one word my first book of what
of what he said to me and he was an
expert right he was somebody who was it
wasn't just some guy off the street he
was a guy who was in thought leadership
did a lot of video content and him
telling me that this would never work
and it was too long that I didn't
understand how things work and a younger
you know less experienced Evan might
have listened to him
but at the time I felt okay I don't know
maybe he's right but I spent a lot of
time on this thing and I liked it
it moved me it inspired me so whatever
I'll just post it who cares if it ends
up being a giant flop then lesson
learned maybe it'll inspire you know a
couple hundred people and
I had fun doing it right and so we
released it and at the time my best
video had a hundred thousand views in a
year and I was so proud of that video
man a hundred thousand hundred thousand
views in a year that's awesome
this video launched and I did a hundred
thousand views in a month
it ended up being my best video on the
channel it's not anymore but was the
best bit of my channel for maybe a
couple years
[Music]
now it's got you know a couple million
views on it and it's just a reminder
that I'm trying to do something big you
are where you are because of your
environment the easiest way to change
where you are right now and if you're
not happy you want to change where you
are right now in life the easiest way to
do it is to change your environment
change who you hang out with change your
videos that you watch change what you
wear change where you go change your
habits when you change your environment
it automatically triggers new thoughts
new beliefs new mindsets inside you
where if you hang out with the people
who are not living the life that you
want you're watching the videos of
people who are tearing each other down
instead of educating and lifting people
up when you're constantly surrounded by
negativity and small-mindedness guess
what you become
if you can switch it if you can choose
consciously to make a change in your
environment towards a better life that
life will start to manifest
so when I was on my tour
in 2019 it was the first time I got to
meet John Ashraf I was going to San
Diego and John's team heard that I was
doing my tour and said hey if you're
coming to San Diego would you like to
interview John for your Channel
uh yeah yeah yes I would
do that very much how do we make that
happen and uh we we scheduled it it was
not part of my initial tour we had to
move things around to make that happen
and we had the fortune to spend I don't
know half of a day with John we went to
his office
a neurogym we did the interview we hung
out we talked about YouTube uh met his
team and there's the knowledge exchange
which is great where I got to ask him
questions and hang out and we I don't
know how long we spent there on the
actual interview but more important is
the energy exchange more important is
when you're hanging around somebody
who's accomplished a lot it it makes you
want to do more you know when you're
around people who are more fit than you
it makes you want to be more fit when
you're around people who have a great
relationship it makes you want to have a
better relationship when you're around
people who've had success in business it
makes you want to have more success in
business and the challenge and a big
reason why I make all of my content is
because
you are probably the most ambitious
person that you know you're the most
ambitious positive happy uplifting
person in your circle and that's
fantastic and that's a gift that you
give to other people because you're
encouraging and looking them up but
there's nobody pulling you forward
there's nobody who you're hanging out
with who says you could be doing more
and so hanging out with John Ashraf and
at his place in San Diego was another
extra push it's like this is
this is something that I want more of
these are the people that I want to hang
out more with even though I'm
introverted and shy and don't like to
introduce myself to people and think
that I suck at networking uh it's still
important to spend as much time as
possible with the people who inspire you
to live a better life whatever that
version of your life is so I'd encourage
you to look at your your calendar look
at your schedule look at what you're
doing right now look at how you're
spending your time
how much of it is actually dedicated to
the thing that you could be the greatest
in the world at
and for too many people it's it's not
enough for too many people it's zero
you have ideas and hopes and dreams and
Ambitions and goals but there's nothing
in your calendar we're actually spending
time focused on it
the best thing you can do to set you up
for a life of Happiness fulfillment
purpose income all of it is to
drastically change what's in your
calendar
to spend more time developing your
Michael Jordan level skill ability
genius
period you are what you consistently do
the problem for people watching this
video for you your problem is that you
know where you want to go you know what
you want to accomplish you actually even
know the habits that you need to do
you're just not doing them consistently
you get motivated you get inspired you
get pumped up something happens in your
life that then makes you want to go and
drive further Harder Faster let's go
and then you fall off the track
you go back to the old ways you go back
to your old habits and then you don't
end up accomplishing your goals even
though you know you're capable you know
what's possible you know you could do it
you have done versions of it in the past
but you're not consistent on it that's
the problem and that's what we need to
shift in this video because until you
get off that Loop you're going to keep
running the same cycle over and over and
over and over again knowing that you're
capable of more
knowing that you've got the potential
hard to accomplish amazing things
to serve to make a lot of money
to be the person that you want to be
knowing that that's possible but them
never actually accomplishing it we're
going to fix that in this video so I've
got a a model the four stages of
personal development before stages of
personal growth and the first one is the
haters and the haters are the people who
hate their own life and this is most
people most people don't actually love
their own life if you really dug down
and analyze people you ask them about
themselves and how much they love their
life most people will not love their
life most people do not have positive
self-talk when they look in the mirror
most people over judge themselves over
criticize themselves and know that
they're not living the life that they
could be living that's most people most
most of the world hates their life and
it shows up especially in America in in
depression rates and suicide rates like
people are not happy
people are not happy and as a result
they're in a lot of pain and as a result
of that they they hate on other people's
ideas if you're thinking why so many
people will tear down your ideas and
tell you why you can't do it because
they are in a lot of pain themselves
because they maybe took a shot at their
life their dream life and it didn't
didn't happen it didn't they didn't make
it so now nobody around them can be
happy either right
this is the problem I'm trying to solve
you know I'm trying to move people from
the land of haters because I believe
people are good you know I believe
people are good people are good people
want to serve you're built to serve you
want to serve you want you want to help
people are at the core of good and yet a
lot of people are negative because
they're in a lot of pain so that's step
one and that's probably not if you're
watching this video if you're subscribed
to this channel that's not you you're
not the hater but you know probably a
lot of people who are haters
to realize that their dream life is
possible whenever you don't know what to
do the best thing you can do is model
success find the person or the people
who've done the thing that you want to
do learn how they did it apply it to
your situation so you can achieve
similar results and get to your goal
otherwise you're constantly bouncing
around between idea to idea to idea to
idea constantly trial and error trial
and error trial and error and you might
run out of time and it might actually
get too late where if you can model
success the the biggest shortcut to
success is to model
find the people who've done it
understand how they did it apply it to
your life this is the thing that changed
my life I I quit on my business partner
I was 19 years old
me 20 at that point I quit on my
business partner I was just tired of
things not working I was tired of the
business being so slow and sluggish and
and
getting results in making no money I was
tired of it I was everything before that
that I applied myself to I got a result
and here I was trying trying every day
trying showing up to the same place you
went into my business partner's living
room every day working from this dining
room table every day and just not
getting results
and I was tired of it so I quit
and then I woke up the next day and
realized I don't want to quit I can't
quit yet I can't quit it's I'm gonna
regret this
but I can't keep doing it the way I'm
doing it and so
the genius moment out of pure
desperation
was
somebody has done this before I asked
myself who has done this before who has
built a software company before who's
done it I'm trying to solve this problem
I don't feel like I'm an idiot although
I kind of feel like it like an idiot
right now because I'm trying so many
things but I know I'm not stupid
somebody's done this before can't be
this hard who's done this
and that's where it thought of Bill
Gates who started Microsoft in a
he's just one of many he could have been
anybody in software he was just the only
person I could think of at the time and
I learned his story and found out how he
did it and applied those strategies
through him through the partnership so I
thought okay let me get some
Partnerships
and I got my first deal I've said for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars a
little while after and that changed
everything for me that changed the
business that that made me stay in it
that gave me hope that made me feel not
worthless that made me feel like things
were possible
that gave me growth in the company and
it also gave me a strategy for the rest
of my life and that whenever I don't
know what to do
the best thing to do is to model success
the biggest problem
with wannabes is you're watching a video
or you're going to an event and you
think that that's the work that's not
the work that doesn't matter until you
actually do something watching this
video doesn't mean anything unless you
actually take action on it right nothing
changes in your life until you actually
take action on it watching this video
going to somebody's event Listen to
Somebody's podcast might get you
inspired right it might get you thinking
about what's possible
about where you could go
but it doesn't actually lead to you
doing anything until you do something as
entrepreneurs we're Mission driven right
you want to solve a big problem you want
to make a huge change in the world so
remind yourself of what the mission is
and how grateful you are to be on this
path even if you're not where you want
to be yet you're not doing what you want
to do fully yet but you never are there
you never when you hit that goal you you
want a bigger goal and I think that's
great so you're on your journey
and you're much more fulfilled on that
Journey than you used to be compared to
who you used to be
compare your life to where you were five
years ago or ten years ago
the awareness education you've gone
through the the purpose the heart that
you've now discovered and tapped into on
a deeper level
for me I'd be thinking about
helping entrepreneurs
I get to every day wake up and help
entrepreneurs I get to make videos I get
to make content I get to influence
people I get to I get to try to help 18
year old Evans out there who's
struggling with their first business
right
for you what's your big mission
and how can you tap into it and feel it
and it may not have to take too long to
do it but just close your eyes and
actually feel that you touch somebody's
life
again it may not be the scale that you
want it's never the scale you want but
you touch somebody's life
if one person left a comment on your
video one person left a thumbs up on
your post you touched one person's life
tap into what that feels like
that you had a meaningful impact on them
today I would have been the guy who 10
years ago would have thought that's not
possible for me I'm just introverted shy
kid who
just is not a type A personality and
doesn't like networking and will never
meet these people so step one
consume their content even if you never
meet these people just having them
around you daily allows you to start to
shift and start to think like them
allows you to start to adopt their
mindset because they're saying things
that are different than the people in
your life John Ashraf is saying
something different than your parents
right he's thinking a different way than
your friends he's thinking on a higher
level than a lot of the people probably
in your life right now
and so the more that you're around that
virtually by watching videos even if you
never meet him the more you start to
think bigger to have more ambition to
believe that it's possible so part of
your daily routine must must must be
to consume the content of the people who
inspire you to want to be bigger that's
why I make this espresso videos If I
make all of my content on all of my
channels but if it's not my videos if
it's books if it's podcasts
something it's got to be daily though
just like you brush your teeth daily you
need to inject
positivity and belief daily from people
who are doing more than you right you're
brushing your teeth helps you with your
dental hygiene we need to work on our
mental hygiene it's really really
important because the the mental hygiene
will take care of itself in a negative
way based off your current environment
if you are if you are just constantly
battling negativity around you or
small-mindedness around you and there's
nothing that comes into your life that
feeds you with hope and positivity and
inspiration in the sense that you could
do more if there's nothing in that in
your life right now then you won't go
off and do it and so step one is to just
be around the content every single day
in micro doses every single day my new
routine right now is I go for a walk in
the morning and it's about 40 to 45
minutes in the morning and I I watch my
own videos I watch my top 10 videos
while I go for the walk so this morning
I was watching uh Lewis Howes video and
a garyvee video that I made for my
channel and every time I do it I pick up
something new it's a fantastic way to
start my day if you could start your day
every day with garyvee or Lewis Howes or
John assarath or Oprah or Elon Musk or
whoever your life will change
it's why I do these espresso videos I
want to give you the shot event special
every morning your life will change if
you start your day every day with the
people who inspire you they will pull
you up and you don't notice it on a
day-to-day basis but if you look back a
week a month three months six months a
year if you did it every day for a year
holy cow you will be a totally different
person there is always a way there is
always a way there is always a way there
is always a way there is always a way
when you feel stuck when you feel
hopeless when you feel like the world is
against you and you've got big ambitious
goals remind yourself there is always a
way there is always a way
entrepreneurship is always about how
resourceful you are instead of the lack
of resources this is where people get
caught up you wish you had more money
you wish you had a different education
you wish you had different parents you
wish you lived in a different country
you're so focused on the things that are
not going right in your life instead of
focusing on what can I do with what I do
have there is always a way wife has to
go shopping on filming day great I'll
film in the car with Timo hi Timo high
five good boy
hey he's so cute uh business shuts down
my dance studio closes down because of
covet great Move online like there's
always a way I was telling my friend
Mark about
how I got the Honest Company for my book
your one word so I don't know three four
five years ago I don't know how long ago
how long ago when did Euro one come out
it doesn't matter
um I wanted to get the Honest Company
because they built their business around
their one word honesty and they were you
know 100 million dollar plus company
wanted to interview them there was only
one big problem I didn't know them
I had no connection in and I I wrote in
and I didn't hear back and I really
really wanted the company so there's
always a way remind yourself there's
always a way so what I did was I wrote
to TechCrunch and TechCrunch at the time
was the biggest you know blog slash
website slash news site for the tech
industry and I said hey
I messaged the the managing editor who I
did not know either right just cold out
of the blue said hey I'm writing the
book and I'd love to do an interview
with the Honest Company
and if I did an interview with the
Honest Company would you publish it
we're going to talk about these topics
uh and he said yes
we just interviewed the managing editor
out of the blue and he said yes great
now I can go back to the Honest Company
and say Hey I want to do an interview
with you for my book and for TechCrunch
and that got me in the door
right and that then that led to me doing
the interview and flying to California
and meeting Christopher gavigan who's an
amazing human uh and doing the interview
and
getting my book done
and so I didn't know the Honest Company
I didn't know TechCrunch I had no
Connections in
but you remind yourself there's always a
way and that's how you do it you find a
way
what can you do with what you do have
right now how can you be a resource how
can you be an asset how can you help the
people around you so that you can move
closer to accomplishing your goals as
well so how do you do it you know it's
easy to say great Evan uh you don't
understand me I'm stuck in the situation
right now how do I get out of it
everybody's against me I tried a million
I tried everything I tried everything
and it's not working how do I get out of
it it's a couple things you need to do
number one if you are stuck kind of in
the middle of it if you are stuck
feeling overwhelmed feeling it's not
possible Feeling Just you've tried
everything and you're gonna give up
step number one is you have to take a
break from where you are right now
go outside go for a walk breathe
meditate because when you're in when
you're in the lowest of the low
me saying be more resourceful there's
always a way you can't actually hear it
you're not ready for the message yet
because you're too low
this is why a lot of us when we're
trying to help other people the people
around us and telling them you're going
to make it you can be great they can't
hear it because they're too low so you
have to get them back to normal State
you have to get yourself back to a
normal state so that comes from some
getting outside your environment right
now go for a walk get some fresh air do
some breathing meditate pray whatever
you need to do to get back to a normal
state so you're not a depressed human
but you can actually be open and
receptive to a message I'm here making
videos for you because that's part of my
routine
you know I'm recording this on a Tuesday
every Tuesday I make videos every
Tuesday I make videos every Tuesday make
videos every Tuesday I make videos
I've made videos feeling sick I've made
videos with no voice and I held up signs
I made videos with a concussion and a
broken neck I make videos that's the
difference between an achiever and a
high achiever
is that you show up when everybody else
would give you a break when everybody
else would say take it easy when
everybody else would say you're pushing
too hard everybody else says you're too
obsessed
you say no I'm committed to my goals I
committed to making this happen
because you are what you consistently do
we tend to try to over correct things if
you have a goal of eating a certain
number of calories or sticking to a
certain weight and you go and you binge
one day we tend to try to over correct
to say that's it I'm going on a 24-hour
fast you know I'm just not going to eat
anything for 24 hours or if your
business you let yourself down you don't
deliver you don't promise you don't
follow through on the Promises you say
you're going to make videos for YouTube
and then you don't do it and then the
next day you wake up I'm done with that
I'm going to make 80 videos today or
whatever the number would be we tend to
try to do too much in the short run
and that's not where the gains are made
right you could go to the gym and have
an amazing session
but if you're not consistently showing
up to the gym you're not going to get
the results that you want same thing for
the gym of Life the gym of business the
gym of of your mindset it's what you do
consistently every single day and that
can sometimes be boring
and that can sometimes be that you're
you're chasing the wrong thing you're
doing somebody else's routine instead of
your own but if you want to be a high
achiever if you want to show up
for yourself for your family for the
people around you for your customers the
people who you know you can serve you
want to show up as your best self every
day for them the key is that you stick
to your habit try to be a person of
value
being a person of value means what does
this person care about and how can you
help support it so if you're trying to
be a person of value to me what am I
what do I care about right now you know
the easiest thing to do is look at my
Instagram bio look at my Twitter bio
look at the things that I'm promoting
right now right now if uh right now I'm
talking about build to serve a lot it's
still something I care deeply about
right now I'm talking about movement
makers I'm talking about brand lytics
these are the programs that I'm
launching that I care a lot about so how
can you help me with that
what is John astraff watching go look at
his Instagram bio his Twitter bio what
is he promoting right now that's what he
cares about right now to be a person of
value you want to be the person's chief
goal officer what do they need right now
what are they promoting right now what
are their goals right now and then
finding some way to help them
even if it's just being the best person
in the comments
right I have an amazing community that
you guys are amazing
it's what makes me want to keep making
contents because of how fantastic you
guys are and there are some people who
watch the videos and then never leave
any any comments leave comments guys
there are some people who watch your
video and leave a comment and then there
are the special few who watch your video
leave a comment but then we'll also
comment on the other comments not in a
promotional way not just saying hey
check out my new channel I've worked
really hard on it let me know sub for
sub but in uh in a encouraging positive
optimistic way in just trying to cheer
the other people on and supporting them
those people are extra special and there
are there are some people who
I would do the best that I could to try
to support them I'll get hit up every
day with different promotional
opportunities hey Evan can you link this
up can you shout me out can you check
out my business plan and it's usually I
know because I don't even know who you
are
but there are other people who have
brought so much value to my community
that I would I would do my very best to
try to help them because of how much
they've helped me even though they may
not have ever bought anything that I've
done just because they were so valuable
in the community
right so that's your goal your goal is
to be a person of value to be the chief
goal officer and then be a person of
value to them and their community so
they start to recognize you if you don't
like something in your life
you can change it
this is why we become entrepreneurs
because we don't like something that's
going on in our lives in the in the
world you know the people around us we
don't like the way something is done and
we're committed to change it that's why
entrepreneurs are going to solve all the
world's major problems we're not waiting
on government we're not waiting on big
corporations it's us we're gonna we're
gonna solve the problems you you are
going to solve the problems if you don't
like something
when most of the world is stuck in
complaining and blaming and mediocrity
and unhappiness and excuses and I'm too
old and I'm too young and I don't have
the resources and blah blah blah well
most of the world is stuck in that
you're off saying I'm gonna make a
change I'm gonna make that happen and
it's just the mindset shift that you
have to make and keep and sustain on a
daily basis because it's so easy to fall
back down into limited thinking into
fixed mindset into mediocrity to feel
like I can't do this maybe maybe it
can't happen maybe it's not for me maybe
I'm not the person maybe I'm not good
enough maybe I don't belong Maybe
it works for other people but not for me
right it's so easy to go back to that
zone
but if you don't like something in your
life or your community or the world
you can change it be the change you want
to see in the world that's you where do
we learn to be great managers you don't
learn it in school
you'll probably not be a great manager
at the beginning so I think the best way
to get going is to actually hire
somebody part-time the first person I
hired was for one hour a day
one hour a day I hired them for one hour
a day one they were better at at the
thing it was doing database stuff than
than I was so it freed up an hour and a
half of my time every day
because he was better at it than I was
he could do it faster and two it also
got me used to managing somebody on a
small scale before being fully
responsible for them before I was their
entire income and had to learn how to be
a good boss a good leader a good manager
good Mentor good coach
I could I could play
on a smaller scale and develop the
skills and so I think people wait too
long because they feel like they have to
have a giant budget you could hire
somebody for one hour a day
you know instead of buying
Starbucks
you know I don't know how much this cost
five bucks four bucks whatever
right instead of buying Starbucks every
day
you get two coffees that's
eight to ten bucks
you hire somebody for 10 bucks an hour
to do that thing for you
one hour a day that frees up your time
to go do other things
so I want you to start being more
resourceful to try to find other ways
through instead of thinking I'm by
myself I'm all alone I can't do it
there's a famous expression that goes if
you want to go fast go alone if you want
to go far go together
you have to build a team your mission is
too big your purpose is too big
to make your dream happen
you have to focus in on your Michael
Jordan level ability and to spend more
time doing it to stop spending time on
the things that don't produce value and
that you don't have a lot of interest in
I had to start thinking about how can
the people around me support me better
and if they're not going to support me
how do I find people who will
because your purpose is too important
you haven't even come close I've tried
everything you haven't even come close
to trying everything how many things
have you tried
20 there's a million things you can do
you have not even come close and don't
use that as a beat yourself down that's
a push forward to say there's a million
more ideas inside me there's a million
more ideas inside me that I can use to
accomplish this goal there is always a
way remind yourself make it your Mantra
put it on a t-shirt there is always a
way and you are going to find it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there be super clear on what you want
out of life and then go find people
who've accomplished exactly that and
learn from them who you spend your time
with is who you become so Choose Wisely
because most people